today november 21st is world philosophy
day as
declared by and suggested by the united
nations agency unesco so i'd like to
wish all of my viewers out there and
anybody else who's
seeing this a happy philosophy day not
really sure what that is but since i'm a
member of the profession
it behooves me to to extend
the
felicitations the
whatever it is that we're doing
and
what it looks like unesco has been doing
and suggesting is they pick a theme
every year
and then they organize a few conferences
and i think they probably you know
shuffle some money around and get people
to give talks and things like that
i'm on the periphery of that because i
don't i don't pay
anywhere near as much attention to what
the un does as i probably ought to given
what a big role they have in the world
and i'm a practicing philosopher you
know i teach i write
i shoot these videos
doing philosophy by its very nature
requires a good bit of reading and
thinking and reflecting
and making
uh false starts so there's a lot of
overhead you might say in terms of time
and attention
and uh and work
so i don't have an awful lot of time to
to follow up on these things but
i think it's a great idea to have a
day
devoted to thinking about philosophy
and trying to make it a bit more public
so
the theme that they selected this year
is not one that i have a lot of
affinities with
but i think i can say something about it
what they chose was inclusive societies
and
um sustainable planet
and whenever i hear people talk about
that sort of stuff using that kind of
language
i'm always immediately put on my my
guard as a philosopher
particularly as somebody who teaches
critical thinking
because
inclusive and sustainability and things
like that are words that are so
all over the map
and if if you make them general enough
well then who the hell is against any of
that sort of stuff who's against
sustainability uh if you make it super
super general and you know big tent
encompass everybody
um but then if you try to narrow it and
make it more specific and give it some
more
legs or more teeth if we want to use
that kind of metaphor it starts to
become a bit more exclusive
and oftentimes a bit more ideological
and there's you know multiple meanings
and people jump back and forth between
these meanings so i'm always a little
bit
cagey when it comes to these things same
thing with inclusive society
one person's inclusive inclusivity can
be another person's form of exclusion
the you know the
emphasis on on
being
inclusive can sometimes alienate some
people
and you know you might say who could
possibly be against that well again it
depends on what shape you give it
so i don't really want to talk about
those things what i want to talk about
instead
is
how
i see philosophy
in the technosphere
fitting into this
so what i have in mind
is
the sort of thing that we're doing right
now
where
i'm talking to the the camera through
the camera after i uploaded on my
my mac i'm going to
well i have to edit it first but i'll
upload it to youtube and then people
will watch it and they'll have reactions
they'll think about things they'll put
comments
now stuck in google plus you can see my
last technosphere reflections about that
and i'll respond to
some or all of those comments and other
people may respond to them as well
and
through this process
we get to in some way or another do
philosophy in the sense that
we're reflecting on on the process of
philosophy and and the content that's
out there
and
that by itself is is inherently
philosophical
so
what is going on with philosophy in the
technosphere um i i think i have more
questions than i have answers
and this is something that i think
is inherent in the nature of the matter
that we're talking about when we're
talking about the technosphere
what i have in mind in particularly in
particular sorry
is everything that's based in the
internet
now the internet itself is is
if you get down to
the very basic level it's a lot of
hardware
connected up in different ways you know
in some cases with these gigantic server
farms that that our clouds consist in
and these cables going everywhere
and signals going back and forth
but it but it's also
a network of meaning that is in the
process of encompassing us and changing
our consciousness
and our actions and the environment in
which we
we work and i don't want to say that
this is something absolutely radically
new because each form of communicational
technology and other types of technology
logistics technology mechanics
um
transportation
you know you you name it food production
all of those have
affected culture society
consciousness
and and they've
made a uh
an impact on philosophy as well
so
philosophy can engage in reflection
about this entire process and i think it
probably should and i think in doing so
it's actually
going back to its roots if you look at
aristotle for example
and the politics what you see is him
reflecting on
how
conditions of life
among other things how conditions of
life affect the kind of culture that's
available and the technology that's
being used
makes certain things possible and other
things impossible and then you have
social organization that ties in with
that and then you have culture and you
know people choosing to do this or
choosing to do that and and undertaking
projects
but there's this attentiveness to our
environment
as a human formed environment which
interacts with the natural world
so i think that's that's important for
philosophy and philosophers to think
about
and i
myself i believe that having a formation
in the history of philosophy
oddly enough you might think well what
does that got to do with it it wouldn't
be better to be a you know philosophy
science person or philosopher technology
person or philosophy language person
no i actually think that having a good
grounding in historical
figures
is probably the most promising way to go
probably a very controversial thing to
say but
there it is
so
what else
there's this
the other thing that we can talk about
is there's this massive availability
of
resources for studying philosophy for
learning about philosophy for talking
about philosophy for engaging with other
people about it for organizing meetups
to to do things for proposing new
projects
it's as if the the
the sky is the limit
for doing philosophy and in other
respects i mean think for example about
the bentham project you know you've got
these
crowd-sourced
transcriptions
of bentham's works into digital form
which makes them then available for even
the people who didn't sign up for that
like myself i'm i'm you know i'm not a
benthamite nor am i
uh particularly an admirer of bentham
but i like teaching him and i like
talking about him and thinking about him
and the bentham project is something
that's been a real boon to the rest of
us and there's a lot of things out there
like that you know oftentimes these get
called the digital humanities
so there's a lot of really interesting
things going on i think youtube is um
not only with with new content being
made by people
in the philosophy business but also with
putting
online all these great documentaries
that have been done over the years about
about philosophers
and
there's been an incredible
i i'll use the word democratization
not in the sense of
voting
or
political participation
but in the sense of of making it
available for those who are not in the
small
elite whether that's a political elite
an economic elite or an academic elite
because there are elites in academia as
well
which do you know do tend to dominate
they get the grants they get the the
publications they they churn out you
know the the people who are going to
have contacts
instead these these new technologies
they're what they call disruptive
because they allow
you know for example somebody like me
who went to a low tier
graduate school who didn't make a lot of
important contacts whose work is kind of
all over the map and hard to to identify
with one little niche area in philosophy
which is not a not a good job
um
idea if you know if you're thinking
about getting into philosophy you
probably should specialize in something
so that you know they can identify you
as that
it allows somebody like me
to be able to reach a wide audience
and if people like what i'm doing then
you know
there's support for it
and
youtube you know itself has been helpful
with that with making me part of
their their their content producers
program
um
and all the you know all the viewers who
leave comments and thumbs up things and
uh
share
videos
they're all part of that as well and i'm
only one out of
quite literally
not just dozens but at least hundreds of
people doing philosophy in public ways
in youtube on the internet
um
many of them doing very interesting
things
i'm going to get to talk a little bit
about the diversity of that a bit later
so
you know i've got some some i've talked
a lot about this now so i've got some
kind of big questions
like where are we going with this
um i'm also worried about things like
what happens if the web ever does go
down
um you know some of these massive server
farms some some you know act of of
nature or god or you know war
uh wipes out some some portion of them
you know where do these videos go what
happens if if youtube and google someday
go belly up um
that's one set of questions another set
is what is this going to look like 10
years from now
i mean if you think about it
the internet as we know it
has only been around for a little more
than a generation
and most of us didn't get really into it
until about you know
several years
into its its development
um
we have smartphones we have all this
integration of data
we have this capacity to generate
content to share it
to discuss it like we've never had
before
and you know at every any given moment
whatever we think is is cutting edge
is not going to be cutting edge
20 years from now
or 10 years from now
just think about the functionality of
youtube originally when i got into it
and that was just
five years ago i think you could only
make 10 or 15 minute videos so i
actually had to upload my videos into
an institutional channel because
institutions could have
longer videos that's what my my first
videos the critical thinking videos
actually belong to fayetteville state
university
and then i remember when youtube opened
it up to
anybody to to do longer videos
and i was limited in part by
the technology of the camera it was hard
to find a camera that
could actually run
without overheating and the battery
going after more than an hour so an hour
was about the the limit for those sorts
of things and you know things have
gotten progressively more and more
sophisticated over time
what are we going to be doing what are
the platforms going to look like for
for education and sharing of culture and
advancing of culture you know producing
new things engaging in new discussions
on the net 20 years from now
will it be on computer screens or will
it be
something directly in front of us i
don't know you know these are very open
questions and what does it do for
philosophy
that's where it gets very interesting
i think that a lot of opportunities are
opened up for philosophy to
be taught to be to be shared to be
thought about to be accessed
there is this democratization that takes
place where
things become readily available to a
wide mass of people who ordinarily
wouldn't have access to that
and they are also able to be producers
if they if they so choose to
um and that you know that could lead to
some some garbage being produced but the
elites can produce garbage just as
readily i mean you just have to look at
the history of 20th century philosophy
and quite of the literature that's been
written to realize that a lot of it's
just
a waste of time um but you know that
stuff will get weeded out
over time
and the good stuff will will remain
um
so that's you know
that's a lot said there
one of the things that that i i think is
important to point out so i'm shifting
topic a little bit is that in
other developed countries educational
system philosophy tends to play some
sort of role you know i had one of my
videos recently
um excerpted from for
porto
what is it porto editora
who wanted to produce some some
multimedia things for the portuguese
national curriculum where in 11th grade
while 10th grade and 11th grade this is
for 11th grade stuff they are learning
about existentialism they're learning
about philosophy of time they're
learning about philosophy of religion
i wish we had something like that here
in the united states
it would be very valuable for us if it
wasn't just reading
writing
you know english language arts whatever
you want to call it mathematics
science
where she really should be sciences
and then social studies slash history
slash you know whatever you you call it
with a few other things kind of
sprinkled in here and there and i'm not
knocking any of those i'm just saying
that philosophy really ought to be part
of the curriculum if you were if
americans were as serious about
giving their kids a solid quality
education
as europeans were
well taught philosophy not not
necessarily the philosophy that you
might have had with a crappy instructor
in an intro class you know when you were
in college or something like that but
really quality taught philosophy would
be a part of that because it's
part of human culture
and
you know
it was an important part of um
american culture for quite a while
so
even in college unfortunately um
there's not a lot of philosophy
getting taught in comparison to the
other the other subjects and and
oftentimes
philosophy is getting taught in other
areas you know if you want to study
alexis de tocqueville you generally have
to go to a poli sci department to do
that
but they look at you weird because there
it's political theory and they're more
into quantitative stuff for the most
part
a lot of it gets taught in history or
english some in communications but it
often gets taught
not so well
and it would be it would be very nice to
see people having
greater access to that the other thing i
have to say about that
that issue is
philosophers historically have not done
a very good job
in
teaching their their
their texts and in
making philosophy something that people
could actually see value in
there is this kind of
elitism
inherent in it
that went along with well why should we
have to justify ourselves it just sort
of stands if you're asking that sort of
question obviously you're you know you
have these utilitarian mentalities and
there's nothing that can be done with
you you know that's fine to do when
there's no budget crises and you're not
called upon to actually justify your
existence but that resulted in
philosophy being marginalized
i would say that um
you know the predominant movements in
philosophy in the anglo-american world
and i have in mind analytic philosophy
what's called continental philosophy
which is not really european philosophy
but just a small sliver of it
and then a sort of you know
watered-down
textbook-based
version of the history of philosophy
have really done a terrible disservice
in giving people
first off an impression that philosophy
is mainly about either
indescribable things that can't possibly
be fathom let alone connected up to real
life or is just about you know
playing around with arguments and logic
where it's just about shrill critiques
of things
uh each one you know layered upon the
next or is just about learning a few
basic ideas that you could probably make
trading cards of you know for different
philosophers like here's your descartes
you know mind body problem
hyperbolic doubt um
that's
that's really done a disservice and
anyway
um i think that
doing philosophy on the internet
provides some remedies to this
one of the the most frequent comments
that i get
on my youtube videos
is
from people who are taking classes
and they're having a hard time
understanding their textbook or the
readings or their instructor
and they're just not getting out of the
class what they want to and after they
watch these these lecture videos many of
which are me you know teaching to my own
classes as students
they
have a better handle on descartes or
aristotle or kant or or hegel or whoever
and so i think that that's you know
that's in part because of what i do
but um
that couldn't happen if it wasn't for
the medium
and if it wasn't for other people
sharing that stuff and if it wasn't for
the fact that
by being on youtube
you know this this whole thing has been
sort of equalized so anybody can type in
aristotle three forms of friendship and
my videos could come up along with a lot
of other people's videos and whoever the
viewers have actually found the most
helpful are probably going to be close
to the top
so there's a lot of resources available
um
one of the things i think that we ought
to think about and this goes to the
question of inclusivity
inclusive societies
uh this this great theme for philosophy
day who generates the resources
are there opportunities for doing this
in in the american educational system if
you wanted to get into
doing philosophy online
there'd be a variety of resources for
you a lot of platforms that you could
use
but if you were less of a self-starter
and or an experimenter and you wanted
more institutional support
it would really depend very much on your
institution how
how into that sort of thing are they
and the big institutions have a ton of
prestige and they have used that to to
dominate certain areas like itunes u
or you know the whole mooc phenomenon
which i'll do another video about we'll
talk about the moocs
because i i think that there's some
problems with that that have to do
precisely with democracy
and with elitism
um
so you know how are these opportunities
created youtube is kind of a
a nice place to be in part because you
can get in without having to be from a
big name institution without having the
right people writing letters of
recommendation for you or giving you a
reference or or something like that you
just shoot videos and if you're any good
and people like what they're they're
seeing then you know you'll you'll do
okay
um there's a lot of different platforms
out there there are more platforms right
now available
than
i can actually
get into and i'm i'm one of the people
who's really interested in this sort of
thing
i've got a few classes for example on
curious.com
and i'm going to be doing some more on
that
and there's another place that got in
contact with me called video class and i
may do some work for them and there's
some there's some places that have been
creating platforms for actually creating
real full classes and i may be doing
some of those with them
there's you know udemy
uh mooc.org
has finally started to solicit
non-elite institution
uh
participants
and so i i you know sent in my stuff to
them
there's a lot of different places that
are that are doing interesting work um
not all of it is you know super high
quality
but
you know again i think that that
better quality will will start you know
being recognized and rising to the top
there's a lot of already existing sites
on the internet as well and one of the
things that needs to be done you see
people like the sailor foundation doing
this
is to try to bundle together
all of these sites to curate them to say
you should go here and check this out
learnest by the way does does something
quite similar as well
so you know for any instructor
who wants to
teach online or develop a class or reach
an audience or something like that
you don't have to reinvent the wheel
because there's a lot of resources
already available out there and you can
do kind of a hybrid of saying how about
you check out these
videos and these handouts and these
websites and these you know encyclopedia
entries and then i've got some other
stuff here for you and we'll have some
uh
you know video chat uh
sessions where we'll talk about this
sort of thing
there's a lot of possibilities for for
this
um one of the things that i think is i'm
bringing that part to a close is really
important
is that we we don't
lose
sight of the fact that that philosophy
is something that existed before the
internet
um
that it's its relevance its usefulness
is not you know restricted to what we
can make of it on the internet because
there's a kind of uh tendency as with
anything else
to
you know get a little too too narrowly
focused on that sort of thing we don't
want to lose our links to the
non-internet world and imagine that if
there isn't a sight on it then then it
doesn't really exist or it doesn't
really matter you know for for example
um
or you know we also don't want to
not read physical books you know you see
my my bookshelf behind me
the fact that we can have everything
digitized and the fact that we can also
have lectures and podcasts and stuff
like that shouldn't deprive us of the
actual
effort of running our eyes across pages
not just screens but pages
trying to assimilate that information to
reflect on it to think about it and
making it our own making it part of of
who we are
sort of like a mental process of
digestion
um
there's two other things i want to talk
about and then i'm going to
say given a sort of announcement about
what i'm going to be doing
so
back to inclusivity there's a kind of
complementarity i don't really like the
word inclusivity for the reasons i've
said i prefer the word complementarity
i end up communicating with other people
who are doing similar work
on the web
in that they are they're doing
philosophy in some sort of public way
maybe maybe making videos maybe they're
producing digitized
translations maybe they are you know
organizing conferences and organizing
communities and things like that using
using um
you know groups or
or other you know circles in google plus
things along those lines
and
what i realize
is that
i don't have to do it all
i i have you know i think like i think a
lot of people i have this sense that
look if i'm going to do it i got to do
it right so i got to do do it all
um
you know it'd be cool if i could make
cartoons about plato and socrates and
aristotle but
that's not my skill set
and there are people out there who do
that sort of thing and you know it would
be cool if i could actually produce
videos that were only three minutes long
and convey a ton of information but
again not my skill set
i do better in sort of meandering
roaming try you know bringing together a
lot of threads i'm kind of that's why i
like hagel you know because that's what
he does in his works
um
when somebody leaves you know one of my
videos if they watch it the whole way
they know a lot of stuff
but maybe that's not for everybody you
know
and i think that there's a healthy
complementarity
where
we're not really competing with each
other
we're
building off of each other we you know
if you if you like what this guy is
doing over here this this woman's doing
over here then you might like what what
i'm doing over here and you know vice
versa
and sometimes we'll disagree about you
know how to interpret nature or how to
interpret plato or what's important to
talk about in philosophy should we be
talking about texts or should we be
talking about problems
but that's why it's nice to have
diversity
real diversity
doesn't mean everybody you know is just
on the same plane and everybody's just
got slightly different backgrounds from
each other marginal differentiation but
they all sort of get along real
diversity is boisterous
and people often don't get along and
misinterpret each other and you know
end up at odds and people listen to them
and they're like boy both of these
people are full of it or they're like
i'm gonna take this person's side versus
that person's side that's real diversity
that's what i would actually call real
inclusivity but it takes guts to be able
to do that
um and you know a certain sense of of
self-respect to be able to allow oneself
to to differ with others like that and
that sometimes is lacking
um my approach is to you know to focus
on classic and contemporary texts and
thinkers
and
to try to apply you know philosophy
through
thinking that's informed about that so
when i think about current events i'm
thinking through
these these uh these classical ideas
that's the way i i am
i'm actually in kind of a strange
position
because what i'm doing is i'm producing
a lot of content that somebody could in
fact use to not do the reading
to just sort of supplement for it and i
don't want to do that and when people
you know put comments like well now i
don't need to read the text i said you
should really shouldn't deprive yourself
of that this is not meant to be
a complete summary of the text but we
live
because of the technosphere that we're
in in what i would call an encyclopedia
culture
where those who are at an intermediate
or expert level on things are producing
content
that other people are using
sometimes the way it's intended to is a
supplement to the the actual you know
original text so you know for example
here's c s lewis is the four loves you
ought to read that book it's a good book
it's not the best book in the world but
it's pretty good
and i can do a video lecture on it and
you'll get more out of the book after my
video lecture if my video lecture is any
good but you shouldn't substitute my
video lecture for actually reading the
book
and if you want to read it online or on
your kindle or something like that
a-okay you know listen to it as a sound
file driving in your car working out
that's fine you should read some books
physically but
a video shouldn't be or a podcast
shouldn't be the only thing
that one actually studies any more than
a handout or spark notes or things like
that
so i find myself in a strange position
where i might be actually contributing
to the development of this this
technosphere
and its content in ways that i don't
myself
fully approve of that leads me to the
last point that i want to talk about
which is i have a lot of people
and i'm going to do some more videos
talking about this i have a lot of
people
from time to time saying
your videos are providing me with you
know an education
and
what i want to say all the time is no
they're not
they're providing you with elements of
an education
which then
you can combine into an actual
education but
just a whole playlist of videos is not
an actual education and shouldn't be
taken as such any more than
spark notes ought to or
um
you know reading a set of lectures
powerpoint slides or something like that
so what is it what is an education that
would be available online through this
this amazing techno sphere that we're
involved in
that's being offered for the first time
to many lifelong learners and many
people who can't afford
a quality education or actually go to
good places and find that their teachers
aren't worth a you know
a tinker's dam
because they're too busy doing research
to actually teach or things like that
um
well you know you've got the elements of
education and that that includes like
doing the reading
handouts that are helpful
lectures
uh podcasts
you know interactive exercises all those
sorts of things
study questions
those are all those are all good i don't
want to take anything away from them but
those those are just the elements that's
the basic level
and then you know what would be at the
very highest level
you're able to integrate these things
yourself and and you know place plato
say in conversation with nietzsche
and have you also be one of the
participants in that and be able to call
nietzsche and say you know i think you
actually got your plato wrong here um
maybe maybe you should rethink this and
what would that rethinking look like
that's at the very high level what's in
between courses
i'm not saying that a course actually
gives you everything that you need but a
course you know takes those elements and
bundles them together
into a set of experiences in which
people are learning at a deeper level
and things that are more lasting and
they're bringing things together so they
get a sense of the big picture and about
how these
different ideas connect and how these
different thinkers are related to each
other where this text fits in
what i really want to see
and what i would really love to be doing
is
offering courses
not just producing videos
i you know i love doing this sort of
reflection stuff and i'm happy to keep
doing that
but eventually i want to be producing
actual courses where there's more
interaction
where there's progress being made where
there is kind of a
sequence and people could you know
the internet offers us a lot of freedom
we could do it you know where
um a lot of it's asynchronous and if you
if you're interested in existentialism
but you're not particularly interested
in chest off maybe you skip that stuff
and you don't come to that online
lecture you know discussion session or
things like that but you just jump right
ahead to the real k or the kafka
or the heidegger you know or if you if
you didn't get the heidegger the first
time around you get to retake that you
know until you actually
fully understand it
that would be amazing
can you imagine an educational system
in which that was the case
where you had students who are able to
choose what they they want to do and if
they want to get you know some sort of
certificate or
you know
credit or something like that there's
certain qualifications that that they
have to meet but they they get to do
this stuff on their own time until they
can they can make sense of it
um
using what what what resources are going
to be helpful for them
and the the content producers keep you
know producing more and more stuff in a
creative way
that to me sounds like
a hell of a lot of fun
and
like it would you know to go back to
this this conte this context of the
world philosophy day
would that have to do with inclusivity
yeah i think it would i think it brings
a lot of people in
that are right now being shut out or
pushed out or left out of education
because of all sorts of gatekeepers and
also because of bad teaching and also
because of uh
you know
their where they're coming from
um
does it have anything to do with
sustainability
yeah you know all this online stuff is
pretty sustainable except for the
massive server farm sucking up lots of
water and environmental resources but in
general
this is pretty sustainable
and it's pretty environmentally friendly
in that if you want to take a class with
me if i've got a class online
we can interact even though you're
half a continental way
that
really opens up a lot of possibilities
the main question that i think we have
to address is is aren't we sucking up a
lot of power
and isn't that being sort of you know
taken
out of the environment
and put on the environment in all sorts
of burdensome ways
that's that's a real issue to think
about
the last thing i'm going to say
is so in honor of world philosophy day
what i wanted to do
originally
was to
hold the google hangout i've been
kicking this idea around for quite a
while
of holding regular
google hangouts youtube also has another
thing that i haven't started
experimenting with doing live events but
i'm not sure that that's actually
interactive people can comment but i'm
not sure they can actually
talk to you at the same time
so
next month
i'm going to do a google hangout
specifically on
philosophy
a way in which i can
interact more with my my viewers
haven't decided on the theme for it yet
and i don't know that it's actually
going to be tied in with these falasso
geek reflections on the technosphere
anything along those lines might be
something more like you know the
research i'm doing on aristotle and
anger or talking about the seven deadly
sins or
you know talking about kant or who knows
but in any case i'm going to start once
a month
doing these interactive sessions and
just seeing
how it goes and and where things go from
there if nobody shows up i guess i'll
just
you have some preset stuff that i'll
talk about but if people want to show up
and talk about philosophy and ask
questions and you know say things that
they want me to to respond to
um
that'll be quite good too and maybe some
of it will focus on technology
so i wanted to do that today but i
i didn't feel that comfortable with
trying to
tie together those themes as it turns
out i did have a lot to talk about that
does tie in marginally with inclusivity
and sustainability on the planet and
things like that but much more about
technology and what it affords so
those are my uh
philosophy reflections
and i'll keep on with with this uh
sequence of videos because there's a lot
of other things i want to talk about in
the future i think the next things that
i want to talk about are moocs